welcome back okay so we've been talking
about the dynamic mode decomposition
which is a powerful data-driven
technique to identify spatial-temporal
coherent structures and a linear model
for how they evolve in time this works
for very high dimensional complex data
and now I just want to walk you through
some of the key extensions and
applications and give you a quick
example of this okay so one of the
really nice things about DMD this is a
figure I made a while back so dynamic
mode decomposition first of all has a
very strong connection to Koopman
analysis so even though we're getting
these linear dynamical systems models
there's some connection to strongly
nonlinear dynamics through the Koopman
operator so the best fit linear DMD
model and the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors are related to I gain
values and eigen vectors of the Koopman
operator and because we formulated DMD
in a linear regression framework because
this is literally just a best fit linear
regression there are tons of extensions
that exist for DMD so it's highly
extensible you can add in your favorite
kind of technique into this DMD Koopman
framework pretty easily just because of
linear regression so this is an old
figure I'm just going to tell you some
of them I put a W here because these are
a lot of the ones that we're working on
there's extensions to DMD for systems
with incomplete measurements so if you
have spatially under resolved
measurements you can use compressed
sensing to reconstruct what the flow
fields are you can also do compressed
sensing in time if you don't have time
resolved snapshots Nathan Cutts
developed a multi resolution version of
DMD so instead of doing one big linear
regression on a long time scale you
essentially can do this Multi resolution
in time DMD so that you can pull out you
know slow modes medium scale modes and
fast modes and what he showed is that
you can capture intermittent and
transient phenomena for example the El
Nino is a transient kind of yearly
oscillation that you can pull out with
multi resolution DMD
that you couldn't pull out with regular
DMD and then we've also been developing
extensions to control so this is work
led by Josh Proctor essentially you can
take DMD and instead of just identifying
a best fit linear model you can also
figure out what that model is if you're
actively controlling your system you can
identify that model and you can control
those DMD models other things you can do
so if you want to apply this to very
very large data you can used randomized
singular value decomposition and random
randomized DMD methods to go to really
really big scale problems so this is
work that Ben Erikson is doing and
there's other groups across the world
that are also doing randomized SVD s and
D MDS on the right you can see some
other applications so streaming is
really important what if I'm getting my
data online and I just want to adapt my
DMD estimate so there's streaming
algorithms
there's denoising algorithms so if you
have corrupt noisy measurements there's
lots of algorithms to denoise the DMD
and then there's also extended DMD
methods that take your original
measurement and augment it with enrich
it with nonlinear measurements okay so
long story short because this is a
linear regression there's tons of ways
of extending it there's literally dozens
of papers that have have resulted in in
future or sorry add-on innovations to
the original DMD algorithm okay in
addition because it's a purely
data-driven method it's been highly
applicable so I'm only giving a few
examples here of the many many many
places that DMD and Koopman have been
applied so it started out in the fluid
dynamics community I'm showing a nice
picture here from a paper by Clancy
Rowley Yegor message and their
collaborators looking at jetan across
flow and using DMD to pull out these
these coherent structures with physical
meaning probably most of the DMD papers
are in fluid dynamics all kinds of
applications from jets to boundary
layers combustion shock turbulent
boundary layer interactions you name it
but since then it has DMD has also been
applied to neuro
disease modeling weather and climate
robotics finance plasmas video
processing tons of applications the
common thread in all of these cases is
that you have high dimensional data
governed by a probably nonlinear process
it's multi scale in space and time and
there's coherent structures
okay there's dominant coherent patterns
and you want to pull out a linear DMD
model for those dominant patterns okay
the last thing I want to show you is a
simple example illustrating how DMD
works on a toy video problem okay so for
this example we're going to look at how
DMD works on a simple toy video this was
a video that was constructed by Bing
Brunton to demonstrate kind of how DMD
compares with principal components
analysis and independent component
analysis so this is an 80 pixel by 80
pixels image so 6,400 dimensional data
there's noise added to this and when I
click go you're gonna see that there are
these two dominant coherent patterns
that oscillate at different frequencies
so you can see there's a fast square
oscillation and a slow Gaussian and so
with without noise this is really a Rank
2 system given by these kind of
oscillating dynamics which is exactly
what DMD is tailored to pull out okay so
what does principal components do if you
just took the singular value
decomposition of this data which is
basically what principal components does
so if you took the the SPD or PCA of
this data you will in fact find that
it's a two mode system so PCA identifies
correctly the rank of the system but
because this is based entirely on energy
or kind of contained variance the modes
that come out of PCA mix these two
frequencies it doesn't pull these
frequencies apart this is the single
most energetic mode and this is the
second most energetic mode so PCA gets
their rank and that's some of the
structure but it doesn't split them up
into these coherent in time oscillations
I see a dozen
better job ica actually does extract two
shapes that correspond to the fast and
the slow dynamics but it does a pretty
poor job of denoising so this is very
very noisy and cloudy and it also
doesn't tell you exactly what the the
frequency component there's no model for
how these are evolving in time and so
finally the dynamic mode decomposition
perfectly separates out the fast and the
slow dynamics into the square and the
Skousen and not only does it separate
out these modes it gives you very clean
estimates of those modes and it
correctly identifies the frequency of
how those evolve in times so there's
this linear dynamical system model under
the hood that tells you how these modes
are going to evolve in time okay so
that's just kind of a nice intuitive
picture of what DM D is doing on a
simple example you can code this up and
try it the code is actually in our DMD
book you can download that off of our
website and try this example okay thank
you